you just have to get started start
something get started now what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in your potential and I want to see that
thing that you have inside here come out
and explode into the world to make it a
better place and so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna learn how to
just start and as always guys as you
watch it if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can learn and
be inspired and when you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
sometimes being young and trying things
are so naive and you don't know any
better
all you do is learn and if you fail it
doesn't matter and so whether I was 9 10
12 1621 the failures were irrelevant and
you know whether you're you know nine
twelve sixteen twenty one twenty two
twenty four you know I'm sleeping on the
couch you know I have a car with a hole
in the floorboard you know I'm living
like a bum and like a student and so
what did I have to lose and so I think
that influenced me as much as anything
so it you know my dad was like go for it
you know don't why not what do you got
to lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch so I think that that was
motivation ideas don't come out fully
formed they only become clear as you
work on them you just have to get
started if I had to know everything
about connecting people before I got
started I never would have built
Facebook movies and pop culture just get
this all wrong the idea of a single
Eureka moment is a dangerous lie it
makes us feel inadequate because we feel
like we haven't had ours yet and it
prevents people with seeds of good ideas
from ever getting started in the first
place mom made it into college on his
third try and became an English teacher
with no computing or engineering
background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he says
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touched keyboard before I never
using computer before and I say what is
internet he's a jack you know such
whatever you want on the internet how
can I search what is such me is it just
the type I said I don't want to type
computer is so expensive in China I
don't want to destroy it
he said it's not a bomb just the type so
I tapped the first to work of beer at
that time very slow come out the
American beer Japan beer in the German
beer but no China beer so I was curious
and I was type of China no China no data
came back to Hangzhou
we threw one dollar in my pocket scared
worried and I came back and I said I
want to do something called internet
your book isn't
I mean it's thick but I should have been
able to read this in two or three solid
days of read yes I told you how
successful I was yes not very and that
bugs daddy and it's a it's a it's a it's
a fail it's a it's a you know what
though I think this is a failure in my
part I I think that this is the same
thing well you were talking about on the
last podcast and I think echo said when
you say oh you know what I'm not gonna
finish this book right now it's it I
don't really want to it's sort of like
when you say oh I'm not gonna
it's not that I want to though that's
what I'm saying you say but I don't want
to do it right now I can push it off a
little bit you accept that do you accept
that answer
mm-hmm you accept that answer the
soldier Jody right wouldn't accept that
answer would not do you self-talk not
really not really I'm not a guy that
says you know I'm gonna do this number
to do that I just do it right I just go
and do whatever that thing is because
the resources had been so limited for so
long there were a lot of people who
would say God if I only had access to a
camera I would make a movie there's a
lot to talk about I remember I was in
college I spend most of my time in my
room writing screenplays really bad
screenplays but I was in my room doing
that when I prize should have been
studying or something there were a lot
of people I remember at parties who
would talk about writing and that they
wanted to be writer but I would always
notice that they were out every time I
would happen to go out they would always
be out and they I just know that that
there are people who talk about what
they would do if but they're not
actually doing the thing and so it's a
lot easier to actually write a
screenplay than you think it is might
not be good but most people talk about
writing screenplays but don't actually
write them the people who write them
you're already like in you know the top
10 percent because you actually have
written it graduated from stay
studied African American Studies and
political science was heavy into
directing and producing plays at school
and then I created my first webseries my
senior year eventually moved back to LA
and just started doing all these odd
jobs and trying to establish myself as a
videographer or an editor and trying to
get worked that way and hopefully by
like in my mind by filming weddings and
filming you know talents high school
talent shows
I'd be discovered by a film director
who'd be like wow you really filmed that
wedding nicely but that wasn't the case
J oh my god that issue wow I haven't
seen you since college why this is where
people who major in african-american
studies end up sweetie I'd started a
black film blog I was super into film I
still am the same types of black movies
were coming out with the same types of
type of humor and it was frustrating and
I was voicing man on my blog and I
remember one comment was like you
complain so much why don't you make
something and that like I was like oh
okay I will
in the first way you should not compare
yourself to others is in terms of
especially today their fans their fame
their followership right their audience
never do that in my industry that's very
very popular to do and it's ruined a lot
of people's lives who don't ever rise up
to serve because they think they're not
popular enough you know it's like that
you write your first book and you don't
have as many sales as other people and
you think oh well I don't have the
audience or you go to someone's fan page
and you see oh my gosh look at their
followership look at how many Instagram
followers they have how many Twitter
followers they have and because you see
them so big you think oh I could never
be that so you don't even begin and a
lot of people do that they say well I'm
not that big so they never start but as
I always say you know what no matter how
small you start start something that
matters begin it if I began my career
looking at my heroes looking at a Wayne
Dyer or a Tony Robbins or a-- marianne
williamson a Deepak Chopra a Jim Rohn
and today or or looking at people like
Augmon dinos who'd sold millions of
books or or even the famous books that
you saw millions and millions and
millions of copies if I gave myself to
that and thought that was the
expectation I would never begin so you
can't expect to start out with tons of
people sub some people say to me all the
time
well Brennan it's so easy for you
because you got millions and people on
your MLS and you have millions of people
on Facebook and tens of millions on
YouTube I say it doesn't make it any
harder for me I still show up and shoot
this video and the reason I have the
followers and the fans and the audience
is because I showed up and I started
when there was only one dude ten dudes
hundred dudes a thousand dudes watching
us my first seminar that I ever did we
we only have 22 people in the room and
now we fill up seven hours nine times a
year often from people from 46 countries
around the world fly-in paying thousands
of dollars a ticket and what did I do
I started with 22 people in a room with
and most of those people didn't even pay
and every time that the guy walked in
with with water I counted him as one of
those 22 like I had no followership it's
never about how big you start it's that
you start and you get big by staying at
it because what people do is they put
out the first video they write the first
book they they tried the first thing
online and nobody follows only watches
and they quit they get disappointed and
where there's disappointment there was
too high of an expectation on
achievement versus learning versus
process versus beginning what you want
to do is never be disappointed and the
way that you're never disappointed is
that you understand every single step
counts every single step is learning
every single step gets you going I
always tell people and it kind of and
it's kind of funny but it's real I
always kind of tell people like the last
thing you want me doing on stage is
thinking you know like you don't want me
to think about anything I always feel
like the best shows are when I am just
up there and just kind of existing and
going through all the motions without I
know where everybody in the band is I
can sense everything all the movements
every song just kind of comes and goes
if I'm distracted at all and I have to
think about what I'm doing I typically
kind of suck in that moment how
how was the game changed with technology
in music well I mean you don't really
need anything anymore you need your
computer that's all you need you don't
need any any keyboards you don't need
anything to produce interviews if you
know the program like good quality music
you know and then obviously you're gonna
have to you know you have to know
melodies and you know that not everyone
can learn that but it's definitely made
it easier for so many people to get into
this and you know get started with it
and and you know a lot of people maybe
that before couldn't afford or didn't
want to risk buying hardware for in you
know thousands of dollars because they
didn't know if they could produce or not
but now it's like all for pretty much
nothing you can just download and it's
amazing things like GarageBand for
example exactly yeah or any of the pro
there's so many programs and you know
it's all about how you work with the
program as well so no it's it's just
amazing how how easy it is to get
started now now a lot of you guys may
not know but I'm a naturally shy person
I know right me yep been that way ever
since I was a kid I get anxiety I'm
nervous to go and introduce myself to
people especially you know sometimes to
talk to beautiful women yeah I'm very
shy I was scared to raise my hand in
class basically just fearful of the
things that I knew that I should do ever
since childhood and it still affects me
to this day so I wish I would have
learned this trick back then because I
would have been more courageous more
confident I would have done more things
try more things save more things that
were on my heart but here's what you do
enough talking when you get that feeling
that you want to do something like talk
to someone you're interested in raise
your hand ask a question or ask for a
raise the longer you wait after you get
that initial feeling the more likely it
is that you won't do that thing that you
really want to do why because your mind
starts to overthink make excuses after
excuses Oh what if I look stupid what if
I get rejected but here's the hack
here's the trick are you ready for it
it's real quick real easy and it works
once you know what you want to do count
down from 5 5 4 3 2 1 and then go and do
that thing that you want to do like a
rocket ship
countdown and then blast-off sounds like
the silliest thing ever but it works it
works based on the science of
metacognition and steady after study
have shown its effectiveness see it
quiets the negativity bias that we have
in us the stinking thinking the the bla
bla the worry see worried is a misuse of
the imagination it does nothing but
drain us of our willpower but when you
focus on the countdown you interrupt the
worry that the doubts and then you can
go and do what it is you want to do
that's it
see you just tricking your mind and see
this is such a great tool to help you
take control of your life and start
living more authentically use this for
things like waking up in the morning and
eating healthier going to the gym
whatever a positive change that you want
to make in your life
this will give you the courage to
finally become the truest version of
yourself how much longer are you gonna
say one day I'm gonna just count down
and do it now I didn't invent this this
comes from the amazing Mel Robbins she
has a great book called the five-second
rule I just finished the own audible
amazing so check it out check it out try
guys let me know what you what happens
what you think and who knows maybe you
can change your life in just five
seconds thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what was the message that stuck most
true to you what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business please leave it down
in the comments below I look forward to
hearing what you have to say I also want
to give a quick shout out to Kelly
Quinton from you and Kelly Q comm Kelly
thank you so much for picking up ten
copies of my book your one word and
giving them out to your friends I really
appreciate the support and I hope
everybody enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]